Yeah.
Preparing for an earthquake is
multifaceted,
multi dimensional.
And the first thing really is being
aware.
Uh,
yes,
I've said that earthquakes and occur
anywhere,
but they're more likely some places than
others.
So you know,
basic awareness of where your house,
where you work,
uh,
where you are relative to the faults
that might cause an earthquake.
That's a matter of public education.
Um,
but once you know what you're a risk
might be,
uh,
you have to bake some sort of personal
judgment or if you're a government,
some sort of social judgment about the
level of risk that you're willing to
accept it is going to be.
And if you're willing to accept or only
willing to accept a low level of risk,
then there are a number of things you
need to do.
You do to ensure that major
infrastructure is resilient,
that our water lines are power lines are
built in such a way so that they won't
break that bridges and highways one fall
down,
that fire stations will remain standing
so that the fire personnel can respond
and that hospitals remained standing,
um,
with respect to individuals in their
homes.
Uh,
if you're in an earthquake zone,
ensuring that your building is up to
code,
if a code exists,
um,
ensuring that you follow that code and
even little things like keeping the
knickknacks away from the edge of the
shelf,
keeping your dishes way back.
Those are the sorts of things that can
make the difference between sort of a Ho
hum boy was at an interesting event to
something that was a disaster.
Um,
and these were all written down.
You can go to the fema websites,
you sgs websites,
there were a whole list of these things.
The problem arises when first you don't
have building codes,
uh,
or those codes aren't enforced.
That was a situation Haiti,
where you don't have the national or
social wealth to actually consider this
something you can do.
I mean they're the,
I don't mean to bring up Haiti
constantly,
but the issue there was that there were
so many sort of day to day problems
facing a Haiti culture in Haiti
government.
That's something that might happen.
Uh,
really can't get on the radar screen.
And you could argue the right or wrong
to that,
but that basically is a situation and
sad to say that's tap us throughout the
world.
Um,
so you know,
the basic things really quite easy to do
if you've got the money to do them and
if you've got the public awareness to do
them and if you've got the political
will to do them.
If you're dealing with the Commons,
if you're dealing with infrastructure,
uh,
where you don't have the political will
or the wealth,
uh,
there are a number of things that the
community is trying to do.
There's a lot of concentration on
building small scale community awareness
so that the awareness of disaster,
the awareness of potential disaster I
should say,
uh,
occurs almost at the household level and
enabling people to make decisions but
also giving them sort of the simple
things that they,
that they could do on a day to day
basis.
Not just for earthquakes but for floods,
for landslides.
Uh,
and for that matter,
for longer term issues like sea level
rise and climate change.
Uh,
you know,
one of the,
one of the key things that we're doing
at our institute and elsewhere is trying
to,
to bring the knowledge we have about
earth processes.
You're said dynamic planet.
It's fun to look at.
We enjoy doing that,
but it affects people.
And one of the things we're trying to do
is to bring that knowledge,
not just throw it over the fence so that
policy makers can use it.
Because,
you know,
there's none of a feedback and that kind
of a system.
Uh,
we really,
scientists need to understand social and
cultural constraints on using the
information.
And in fact,
even the utility of the information that
they provide.
And if I may say,
I think the social scientists and
governments and ngos need to know what
they don't know,
and that's a difficult task.
Uh,
but to be honest,
it's an interesting and important thing
to do and we're getting better at it.